[Música]
sin superar la caída de la unión
soviética
vladimir putin ha dejado claro su deseo
de reconstruir nuevamente los cimientos
de la gran potencia la ideología que
inspira putin está llena de elementos
del nacionalismo el imperialismo
soviético algo que inquieta a los países
vecinos que alguna vez fueron partes de
ese unión para el presidente de ucrania
por lo inicie la ins que la invasión de
ucrania por parte de rusia fue pensada
sólo como un comienzo esto para lograr
el objetivo de putin en el marco del
conflicto hay denuncias que aseguran que
los soldados rusos y las autoridades de
las regiones separatistas del donbass
empezará un proceso de rusificación que
es esto lo vamos a hablar entonces con
zaira vadillo castro historiadora del
school of oriental and african studies
de la universidad de londres gracias por
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24
por supuesto os aire quiero empezar
preguntándole qué es la rusificación
como sea este proceso y que busca rusia
con esto
bueno la clasificación un proceso que
podríamos decir empezó el siglo pasado
con la expansión de la unión soviética
luego de la segunda guerra mundial que
se incluye partes de europa del este y
empieza más bien con la imposición de
los rusos como la lengua
primaria para los gobiernos y para
manejar el día a día con esto también
viene una serie de imposiciones de vídeo
de tipo ideológico en lo cual pues se
promueve más bien los líderes rusos la
literatura rusa y la historia rusa
encima de otras
historias verdad de otros países que
eran parte de la unión soviética que
pasa luego del colapso pues no es algo
que se puede borrar de la noche a la
mañana pero ya a 30 años de la
disolución de la unión soviética podemos
decir que el proceso de justificación
pues ha cambiado no es tan agresivo pero
la nueva ideología de putting de tratar
de traer nuevamente sus aliados a su
esfera de control pues ha promovido que
lucía pues empiece
a dar más becas a estudiantes por
ejemplo de asia central para que
estudian en universidades y de tratar de
establecer razón lazos culturales más
fuertes con países que fueron parte del
bloque soviético en europa del este pero
podríamos hablar que la justificación
fue algo muy agresivo una política muy
agresiva de parte de la unión soviética
en el siglo 20 y que esto después del
colapso de la unión soviética de esa
integración del bloque comunista en peso
empezó a desaparecer no he perdido
fuerza pero si sigue existiendo una
nostalgia entre las generaciones pasadas
sobre la vida durante la época soviética
que ha llevado pues a idealizar algunos
aspectos sociales que se vivieron en
aquellas décadas pero la designación
ahora pues tiene otro digamos otro otro
matiz no viene más bien putin a tratar
de promover una ideología donde el ruso
y rusia se representan como un referente
moral distinto al occidente pero no
podemos analizarlas sin perder de
contexto
los soviéticos
podría llegar a ser peligrosa digamos
son nocivas esta justificación
y
yo quisiera decir que que nos iba ya fue
no porque es una ideología que es
exclusiva que tiende a ser un
nacionalismo muy tóxico en lo que es
rusia y está promoviendo una una
mentalidad a veces muy xenófoba en los
espacios de europa del este y está
incitando a a una violencia hacia unos
valores cívicos que promueve occidente
no en ese sentido yo definiría esa
clasificación más bien como una
purificación no esto es una ideología
que está promovida por el dirigente de
la federación rusa vladimir putin y está
muy centrada en él como persona y su
idea de lo que son los valores y las
moradas y la moral que él considera que
va en
conflicto con los valores y la
mentalidad cívica de occidente o de
europa en ese sentido me parece que es
muy muy peligroso que se siga
promoviendo este
esta guerra ideológica en el pasado
teníamos una guerra ideológica entre el
capitalismo y el comunismo pero ahora
estamos viendo una definición de
justificación a favor de uno con un
concepto moral no los valores de la
familia por decir un ejemplo y todo
centrado en la etnia en rusa y la
cultura rusa hay una clasificación ya
que existe en los países de europa del
este que no
a pesar de luego a pesar de 30 años del
colapso humano soviética todavía
es palpable podemos hablar de esta
guerra en ucrania ahora se puede decir
que está existiendo una justificación
agresiva como se vio como la que usted
habló en algún momento en este momento
en ucrania
bueno en el este de ucrania digamos en
la región del donbass que ha estado bajo
control de los separatistas pro rusos
desde el 2014 y en crimea si se ha
promovido a una justificación bien
agresiva se ha promovido la lengua rusa
por encima de la lengua ucraniana y
también minorías étnicas como en el caso
de crimea que son los tártaros de crimea
que tienen otra lengua han sido en
cierto punto discriminados así que esto
es algo que ya empezó en el 2014 a mí me
parece que en lo que resta es lo que
queda de ucraniano y ucrania está
tratando de enfrentar y borrar ese
pasado de justificación de la época
soviética que todavía se sentía no
todavía se estaba presente en ucrania
gran parte de la población hablaba el
ruso no a la vez que ucrania no logramos
viendo ahora que se le está dando una
prioridad al ucraniano
y no solamente eso sino que ayer vimos
como uno de los monumentos
en homenaje a la amistad entre rusia y
ucrania que fue un monumento durante la
época soviética fue destruido así que
vamos a ver en ucrania un escenario de
dos confrontaciones una justificación
que ya empezó en 2014 izando banderas de
rusia y un poco volviendo una nostalgia
soviética de un pasado que no existe
pero se está tratando de recobrar esos
símbolos comunistas del pasado entonces
estamos viendo lo contrario lo opuesto
en lo que resta de ucrania donde
simplemente se quiere borrar todo
aquello donde autrán esa sociedad rusia
o se asocia a lo que fue la unión
soviética que también es muy peligroso
claro pero hablemos vamos a enfocarnos
en el donbass no se puede hablar de una
justificación digamos en la actualidad
cuando hay ya hay más de 600 mil
personas que tienen pasaporte ruso donde
muchísimas personas en esa en esa región
del tomba no hablamos de donges y
lugares también hablan ruso se puede
hablar ahí de una justificación o esas
personas ya eran digamos rusos que se
fueron a vivir al tumbas
y es difícil de definir porque hay
muchos ucranianos que su primera lengua
es rusa que que su cultura principal ha
sido rusa por décadas no entonces
también tienes étnicos rusos pero esto
es una línea bien difícil de definir no
porque hay muchos rusos que son de padre
ucraniano madre rusa en ese sentido la
justificación a ese ha estado siempre
muchísimos
hay muchas personas fuera de rusia que
tienen un pasaporte ruso que no son
étnicamente ruso ruso no y esto se debió
a que
eran parte de la unión soviética lo vas
a encontrar también en estonia lituania
y el adriano donde tiene poblaciones que
hablan ruso primaria y primordialmente
pero no son necesariamente en rusos no
hay una hay algo muy difícil ahí que que
separarnos en ruso y hablar lo soy en el
caso de ucrania muchos muchas de las
poblaciones bombas
no se puede definir como rusa como tal
solamente el este de ucrania es cierto
que es una región que está más asociada
históricamente a rusia que el oeste de
ucrania digamos el vélez vivo o quiere
no estar dijo que está más cerca de
europa que fue parte del imperio
austrohúngaro pero no no significa que
porque muchas personas tengan el
pasaporte ruso haya una justificación el
pasaporte ruso es algo muy conveniente
para muchos muchas muchas personas en lo
que fue parte de la unión soviética no
es muy común ver personas que tienen
solamente pasaporte ruso por
conveniencia y no significa
necesariamente una justificación yo
diría que la clasificación viene más
bien con imposición de la lengua rusa en
el donbass en crimea no ironizando la
bandera y un poco
menospreciando no el rol de la cultura y
la identidad ucraniana en las nuevas
naciones que se han forjado en estas
nuevas regiones que se han creado